fire with helical was followed whatever
you want to call it and so like the
hands just because you go oh will I do
it in Marathi Dory but I don't think
we'll do it in this so I'm trying to put
it so that you start that ingredients
you put it into a lot of the stuff
you do and now it's sticky
it's because you've started the spiral
but then you stopped it
so I call this a question mark because
it goes like that do it you know you've
got the dot underneath
this
comes here but I've got to continue that
spiral
in Tai Chi when we do Push Hands you're
never supposed to bring your hands in in
Tai Chi or else the enemy gets you
so Tai Chi taught me
keep it away from myself
I have to keep the spiral going so we're
going to do that um
we're going to do that after the break
because what you're doing is you're
getting halfway you're getting all these
bits the wrist is right for sure Naggy
the wrist is right now guys and then now
I'm sudden you're going
it's got it all right now this is uh
this is natural